i think um i think separating the now
from the future
i think it's it's human nature like you
kind of get very transactional and
operational in the now
uh but i think increasingly having been
in this role and having worked with
another wonderful team i've worked with
we're quiet we know that the problems
that are happening in the near ether
around us have to be fixed
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford
welcome to episode 380 we have with us
rashmi prabhakar chief of staff global
services finastra
rashmi is an experienced fintech
professional with 20 plus years of
experience in driving strategic change
in technology transformation initiatives
within banking energy and fentic
industries
and is currently chief of staff of
professional services at
finastra additionally she is passionate
and dedicated in empowering men and
women to achieve their aspirations
by rolling out unconscious bias
mentoring and male advocacy programs to
promote awareness and foster an equal
diverse and inclusive culture
she lives in london with her husband and
children aged 12 and 7
who keep her grounded and ensure she
appreciates the simple pleasures in life
rashmi prakar thank you for joining me
on 20 minute leaders how are you all the
way from london
oh really good the sun is shining it's a
beautiful day
i'm really good thank you
the sun is shining and you're in tel
aviv it's going to be sunset in about an
hour and i'm excited to see it through
this window here but for now
what i'd love to talk to you about is
passion motivation chief of staff
inclusion we have way too many things to
talk about
to fit in 20 short minutes but but we'll
try so rajmi
yeah right before we started you started
talking to me about passion and
motivation
and how that's been a force to be
reckoned with throughout your career
take me back a little bit at your
entrance into the ecosystem and
and how does passion and motivation
guide you
as you journey throughout your career
okay
so thank firstly thank you thank you for
the opportunity um for speaking with you
and kind of sharing this story but um i
started my journey i would probably my
my clearest memory i guess is probably i
was like six or seven years old
um my father was rolling out the first
ibm supercomputers in
india uh and i used to accompany him on
odd weekends when
at that time i didn't realize why he
would need to work on a weekend but i
went along with him and um always you
know
having a look at what he did and the way
he approached
problems and solving it's always had a
very large imprint on me
um and so my journey i guess has always
been based on you know just follow your
dreams
um do what you believe you can do and do
what you believe you can't do as well
there's a huge element of just follow
your dreams and
my journey has literally been scattered
with some risks i've taken decisions
i've taken
um through the journey whether it be
starting my
engineering education in india moving to
the uk 20 years ago
taking on the current role that i'm
currently doing so there's a few turning
points but most of them have been driven
by
i guess my just let me try this out you
know
i'm not going to know till i try it out
so i've always got that kind of
curiosity
and interest in just giving it a go
rashmi take me back to those turning
points i want to hear about your both
entrance to the engineering world in
india and unfortunately i don't know
enough about
the ecosystem in india and what that
what what that was like but also
you know taking on the current role so
walk me through some of those personal
experiences definitely
so my i guess my early journey was into
i guess the full range of software
technology was
probably in my teens when i was quite
excited you know coding was
not like now where it's easy it was much
more harder there were these
ibm machines on which you know black
screens and green
text and a very clunky keyboard that
you worked with trying to build software
for um for firms that you never met
and i think as i as i did my engineering
and i came into that my career i guess
my corporate my first corporate
experience
um i always felt very far away from the
user who was using my software i felt i
felt i wasn't in the story i wasn't
i wasn't able to gauge their reaction
when they clicked on a button or they
used it and
so that kind of made me move to another
firm which was i guess the start of
fintech approximately exactly about in
2000 so 21 years ago
when i joined the i guess the makings of
one of the first few fintechs in
in india um and there i felt really
part of something bigger i i really felt
that i could i could interact with end
users i could ask them what they needed
i could design the screens for them and
i could actually test it and they could
use it and if they had issues i fixed it
so i was kind of involved
it wasn't in a traditional role i did
everything that was required
right from what was needed to be coded
the screens getting the testing done
passing it to the end user
getting their feedback fixing issues so
it really taught me a lot about the
whole
kind of life cycle i guess on the job
um so i found that really exciting and
then i think i put took it another step
further because i was still kind of in
india
whereas my end users were scattered
across the world in europe or in the us
only
mainly in the uk and so when the
opportunity came to move to
london um in whatever i think late 2000
um i just i i had self-doubt a bit and
then i said no you know what i'm just
going to take this opportunity because
you never know
and i like and i love traveling and i
love seeing new places and um
so i said okay so i'm going to take up
the opportunity and i moved over
to the uk 20 years ago in the role of a
database analyst but
that was also an area that was kind of
away from end users
and i said i wanted to actually work
with people who are using my software so
i moved
gradually into a role which was more
business analysis
and project management working and
seeing
things as they were being used i think
that buzz that i get
out of that was just immense and i
traveled a bit i traveled to the u.s
i've traveled in europe and so it just
gave me a different perspective i
learned a lot about myself
as well in along the journey uh about
what made me take um
what made me upset what made me happy i
think i learned a lot about myself
along the journey but it's been it's
been quite incredible
through the years up until the current
role that i have
um so prior to this i did a role at
finastra where i
um rolled out kind of operations and at
the moment i'm rolling out strategy and
transformation so to be in
i guess in a position to drive decisions
rather than receive the decisions it's
quite uh it's a
it's a it's a nice privilege to have i
think and i want to utilize it to the
atm
i i can't imagine and and i'm sure that
that's a
i i can see the passion the excitement
uh resonating just you know even through
the video camera
how does this connect to your love for
for adrenaline
and for these adventures because the fun
fact that you shared with me was that
you you're you're an adrenaline junk and
you'll always jump on an opportunity
like that so how does this
you know this behavior this attitude
in the ecosystem reflects on on that
adventure side of you as well i think
it's uh
it's i think it's just an inherent
personality trait in me to try
something new and i think i that
decision applies whether it's my career
whether it's personal decisions which
i'm impulsive
um but also decisions that are thrilling
or you know
it's almost it's strange but you know
the more i think
now i'm kind of in my 40s i kind of
think life is short you got to live
you you've got to feel a buzz you've got
to feel vibrant all the time
um you've got to find a purpose and i
think a combination all of that makes me
seek out so yeah i think roller coasters
skydiving i did that with nine other
friends uh when i was working with
barclays
we fundraised uh a significant amount
it's not something i would simply sign
up to let's be i'm not someone who would
seek it out and sign up to
but when i see it's for a cause and when
i believe in it and when i've got a team
there's the different kind of buzz about
it i i always give it a go
uh it's like i don't want to let the
team down plus it gives me a buzz
yeah i i love it so i at the
as over the last two and a half years
almost two and a half years we've been
the chief of staff of global services at
finastra so tell me a little bit about
finasteride and what is this uh
role of of chief of staff for global
services what does that mean to you
because
it seems like it's encompassing a lot
but what really what really does it mean
okay so um i joined finance for four
years ago but my current role obviously
for the past two and a half years and
uh when i first joined the role um again
she the chief of staff
was just being shaped in many
organizations i think the only place
that probably had a chief of staff were
the white house and so
it had a it had a different kind of
title
guilded title but the way i see my role
really is
um looking around and making sure that
we are working effectively i think for
me
are we working effectively whether it's
personalities whether it's systems
whether it's processes
whether it's the way we communicate it's
making us work more effectively and
indirectly as our directory as a result
of that
being more profitable being more clear
getting the people more engaged so the
my role actually has kind of three key
areas i drive the strategy
of the um the function in the sense that
we try to make sure that whatever we
uh whatever our vision is from an
organization perspective
we distill it we communicate it to our
people
uh and then thirdly we execute on
projects so it's
understanding what our vision is making
sure it's clear to our people
and then making sure that we and our
people are working together to execute
to it so
it could be bringing new business models
to the market new portfolio offerings
at the moment we're rolling out kind of
cloud strategies so to get software onto
the cloud so
there's a lot of there's a lot of i
guess themes of things that but
my typical day is never the same so i
can never tell you today mondays this
and tuesday is this
uh every day is very varied but the
foundation of what i do is to make us
work more effectively
um and make sure our people are engaged
and come on the journey with us i think
that's kind of the crux of the chief
staff role
so this idea of of keeping the people
engaged
and keeping them motivated and what i'm
hearing you say is that you know there's
all
a lot of noise and you know it's it's
sometimes it's beneficial noise but
there's a lot of
a lot going on all the time and and
oftentimes you do want to point towards
this vision right and you want to make
sure that everybody is aligned
towards this vision in one capacity or
another and so you're taking this role
of chief of staff to
to be that spearhead to say this is the
arrow this is the direction and how do
you line
what is the biggest challenge that
you're observing with with exactly that
what do you notice that is sort of
prohibiting maybe
often teams from doing from achieving
that i think
um i think separating the now from the
future
i think it's it's human nature like you
kind of get very transactional and
operational in the now
uh but i think increasingly having been
in this role
and having worked with another wonderful
team i've worked with
we're quite we know that the problems
that are happening in the near ether
around does have to be
fixed but making sure that whilst your
site is still on the now
you have your eyes into the future what
you want to achieve and make sure that
the things that need to happen to hit
that goal are also happening in parallel
because i think
businesses and teams that actually
thrive
in change times of change are those who
are
not just thinking about the now so i
think we have to obviously look at you
know what's the project we've got to do
this month
but if we say in three years from now
we're gonna launch this
how do we get there and there's like
transformation initiatives that i run to
reach
get us there i feel you you can't do one
or the other
you have to have your eyes you know one
eye of one and one eye on the future and
then
i think you're you're sorted but
typically i think
that's where the the struggle comes with
people
being too caught in the now and not
being able to put their head above the
water and say
there is the light there that's where we
need to go so i feel that's
that's the piece that i've got to work
on the most
and and so how do you then employ it
tactically
into the into the team so fine you
understand that there's you know maybe
there's this misalignment maybe there's
you know disparity
you understand that there's something
different than we should be
working on how do you then align a
corporate you know not a five person
startup but how do you align a big group
of people
towards that vision i think
communication communication
communication i think without a doubt i
think one of the areas i think probably
six months into my role
uh we weren't really doing a lot of
calls and town halls and communications
as much as we do now i think speaking
communicating but i think the the
tipping point for me really came from
moving away from the concept it's very
easy for us to talk about a vision as a
concept
and say this is what we intend to do but
you've got to translate that
down into and if we do it this way this
is what it will mean
and translate that to what the people so
i think i always kind of look at
whatever we do and
and think if i am in their shoes i'm
going to be asking what's in it for me
why why and what's in it for me and if
we cannot give that answer to anyone who
asks that
as in either they're on the journey or
they're not on the journey but you have
to give
a bit of clarity to everyone
because everyone will take away a
different part of the vision or be
delivering to a different part of the
world
for us to meet the end goal and so i
think the why and the what's in it for
me peace is quite key
um and so psychologically i i think a
lot about what people
may take away or i'll say this what are
they
hearing from me i'm i'm always if eva
i'm double guessing myself and
evaluating but
i think changing the concept moving from
concept to reality
so we're doing this and this customer's
got this
successful outcome makes it real for
people otherwise
it's just a piece of paper or like slide
away as we call it
no that makes perfect sense and i think
that your what you're saying now
goes back in a nice circle to where you
said in the beginning this feeling of
being connected to the end user being
connected
to actually what happens in the field
and not just what happens
you know generically somewhere out there
right
yep definitely that makes a lot of sense
and so
when you're looking now as to where you
are today and if you look back you know
at all the the insights you've gained
over the years and the different
experiences if you
if you had to you know dumb it down to
a few key ideas that you would take with
you perhaps even 20 years ago when you
moved to the uk what what are some
things that you're observing now
about your own behavior or your own
outlook
into you know the way you know projects
are run
what what big lessons have you learned i
think
um for me the biggest lesson really is
um i kind of take it back to the company
i started off with
20 years 20 21 20 plus years ago and now
and i think previously the way we were
structured
we did not have functional boxes
that someone would be writing the
software someone would be building it
someone would be
implementing it someone would be
supporting it someone whatever would be
selling
you kind of did everything you can and
you centered it around the customer
and you said this is a bank this is a
financial services institution
they want this outcome and so we as a
company or a firm or a fintech
will deliver to that and it just so
happens
that we are in these functional boxes so
i'd say
for me my biggest learning has been like
where i started
we did not have role we our roles were
not so pristinely defined that we were
stuck
within boxes so we did everything we
could whether it was testing whether it
was supporting
we did everything we could to make sure
the customer was happy and i think
when i come full circle now with the
customer success organizations
and um you know you're trying to
customer success is a huge buzzword over
the past 12 to 18 months or more it's
gonna go on
going and this is what it's looking to
do it's trying to look at it
agnostically of what software the
customer has or what services the
customer has or what they need support
and give a wrapper so that the customer
feels like we are focusing on their
goals and outcomes and i think
to some extent i feel we've come full
circle to creating the
that wrapper for our customer base
no matter how we are internally
organized i think the functional
organization will be a thing of the past
as we start moving it will because
customer teams account
teams that's how we will see um as all
evolve
i i i love those insights say so rush me
thank you so much for sharing them are
you ready for some fun questions
yeah sure all right so we'll start off
easy and we'll get
gradual a little bit a little bit harder
first off what is one of your favorite
subjects in school
k to 12. oh um
i didn't think i had one favorite one
but if i had to pick one i think i'll go
with math
uh mathematics i think um i think i love
numbers
so yeah definitely maths for me and also
i can get it done really quick
i love it all right and who would you
consider as
one of your key role models in life
whether it's
real fictional who who is one of your
role models
so um probably not when i was very very
young i said my dad is kind of
one of my main role models whom i kind
of always aspired to be because of
ambition and drive but on a personal
level
i always admired a sports woman called
peteyusha
she was probably one of the first female
kind of athletes in india so in south
india to have someone
firstly move got into sport
professionally
as a woman many many years ago um but
always ace it always be
the first and you know be focused on it
i i just found that i
i still every time i read about her i
just i just feel
i really inspired that she just followed
her dream and it's quite inspiring
i love it thank you for sharing the rash
me and the last question
it is the hardest one but it's not the
most important one but it's still a fun
one
three words that you would choose to
describe yourself for if i were to ask
anybody at finastra or anybody that
knows rashmi
how would they call you in three words
i think first probably the visible part
which is
enthusiastic i'm always enthusiastic
about anything
um second one um i say quite dedicated
um if i pick something up then i'm i
don't give up
um and the third one i guess a mixture
of uh reliable and persistent
so i um you know you can rely on me
if some if something is um left with me
you can be assured that it will be
sorted out so like
i think that's that's as that's all i
can think about now
i love it rashmi thank you so so much
enjoy the sun in london
and thank you for sharing with me your
insights from your
your time over there and uh and those
are definitely things that i'm
slowly starting to observe myself but
thank you for sharing them i really
appreciate it and stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you so much michael it's been a
pleasure thank you
you